men get more praise now and it's well  now or whenever but i think they get  more praise because it sounds madder  because i want to say we've allowed them  in a sense of we've given them that  power if we were to use our brains okay  me included what do you mean so me  included right i've given people i've  dated the power to have access to me  even though they may not be good for me  if i took it away  you don't have access to me and i feel  like you can be by yourself yeah but  should i be desperate and be hurt  because i don't want to be by myself  i think that's very important  why don't you say on some level you kind  of are what you attract so if you keep  attracting the certain type of guy it  says something  you